pour commencer je vais vous demander de
vous lever allez allez levez-vous avec
moi
allez
merci merci beaucoup alors on se lève
voilà vous êtes presque tous levés et
puis alors on va mettre un bras en avant
un autre bras en avant et on va imaginer
qu'on a un grand sac poubelle entre nos
bras et puis on va exister tout ce qui
encombre nos esprits alors je vais vous
laisser de Giner mais moi évidemment
c'est la charge mentale c'est les textos
des ex ou de la belle-mère le PV
l'assemblée générale le zoom avec les
collègues on en peut plus aller on y va
on y va on y va on y va le rempli on le
rempli de tout ce qui nous énerve allez
ah bah c'est bien vous le faites bien je
vous aime
et alors on va prendre une grande
respiration on va
fermer le sac et puis on va aller
l'envoyer là-bas là là-bas et puis on va
l'oublier
et on va accueillir ensemble un fou rire
allez rier avec moi
bravo
[Rires]
vous pouvez vous asseoir merci d'avoir
tellement bien joué le jeu c'est trop
sympa
ça vous a plu
ça vous a étonné
sans le savoir vous venez faire un
premier exercice de yoga jury la
discipline du lâcher prise
alors voilà moi rire c'est ma passion et
je suis venu vous dire ce soir que c'est
du sérieux
on a tous en nous cet outil merveilleux
qui peut nous aider à dédramatiser
toutes les situations ou presque alors
entre les pénuries de moutarde le
réchauffement climatique la guerre en
Ukraine c'est difficile de garder le
sourire tous les jours vous vous riez
tous les jours
bravo bravo
savez-vous qu'en 1939 on rigolait 20
minutes par jour
versus deux minutes aujourd'hui ouais
ouais je vois vos gros yeux vos
questionnements il faut faire quelque
chose
alors moi j'ai pas peur d'assumer je
suis une militante du rire une
influenceuse du sourire et si ça marche
pour moi et ma communauté je suis sûre
que ça va marcher pour vous tous ici
la clé tout le monde peut rire en fait
sans exception la clé c'est de
réorienter son regard vers le monde et
sur le monde
moi depuis que je suis petite je suis
Julie la coquine
c'est marrant ça vous étonne pas
voilà je fais des blagues à mon
entourage je détourne les expressions
orales voilà je vais les taquiner comme
si en fait mon quotidien était ma cour
de récré comme si en fait j'avais un
super pouvoir une pilule du bonheur avec
que des effets positifs je crois que
tout ça va de tout ça en fait ça vient
de mes grands-parents et mon père des
immigrés tunisiens qui ont dû arriver à
l'âge adulte en France et qui comme
Romain Gary et son arme des désarmés
n'avait que le rire et les boulettes
pour affronter cette nouvelle vie il
faut
ça vous plaît
il en faut du courage pour voir la vie
du bon côté et alors quand j'ai décidé
d'être journaliste
moi quand je suis arrivée dans une rédac
vous avez compris je rigolais trop fort
j'étais trop enthousiaste mon rêve était
de faire un média positif quand
finalement mais que collègues et
camarades ne rêvaient que des trains qui
arrivent en retard
donc bon après m'être battu dans ces
rédactions traditionnelles je me suis
dit que peut-être mon salut viendrait du
digital cette terre promise des contenus
innovants alors j'ai répondu à une
annonce pour être rédactrice rédactrice
en chef d'Instagram et je me suis dit
que j'allais soigner ma page insta pour
être sûr d'être embauché alors j'ai
décidé que maline éditorial ce serait
l'info positive et depuis je n'ai pas
changé
spoiler alert je n'ai pas eu le job mais
jusque 16 mars de villevin bon j'étais
très fier de ma petite communauté de
5000 followers 16 mars 2020 je vous fais
par un dessin tout le monde se souvient
c'est la déclaration du confinement et
moi mon compte s'emballe 15020 mille
followers on était tous sidérés assis
sur notre canapé et je réalise une chose
essentielle l'info positive ça fait du
bien il est bon de se divertir de
s'esclaffer second degré et le rire sont
des outils essentiels pour surfer sur la
vie
comme si le covid avait remis le riz au
milieu du village avait redonné au rire
ses lettres de noblesse
paradoxalement c'est souvent dans les
situations les plus dramatiques qu'on a
besoin de rire qui n'a pas rit un
enterrement
une nerveusement souvent un je vous
l'accorde alors je réalise d'ailleurs
même à ce moment-là que mon surnom donné
par mes amis à l'adolescence ma mousse
peut devenir un verbe je m'amuse tu
t'amuses ça m'amuse beaucoup
c'était pas prévu
alors c'est quoi mon job aujourd'hui je
suis productrice de bonne nouvelle et
sur insta je relai tous les comptes qui
me font marrer meilleur boulot non
et j'ai abandonné l'info traditionnelle
et je me nourris que de même c'est
publications rigodotes et je vous
encourage à faire de même
par exemple alors on pourrait regarder
l'actualité par le prisme de l'humour on
va revenir au confinement et on se
rappelle cette ruée vers le PQ les
farines les pâtes voilà considéré comme
des denrées rares comme en temps de
guerre alors là il y a chez Mamie par
exemple et puis il y a aussi chez Denis
et puis évidemment je vais vous parler
et tout le monde se souvient de la
solitude départ en qui se retrouvait à
faire court à leurs enfants voilà
c'était pas toujours facile l'école à la
maison voilà alors à même ça peut être
aussi un dessin mais ça peut être aussi
un film une scène culte voilà avec Jack
Nicholson par exemple
alors voilà
ça voilà ça fait pouffer ça fait rigoler
et c'est même quand on a le cafard
regardez à même ça apporte de choses
essentielles prendre de l'actu donc mais
la prendre immédiatement avec du recul
en fait ça résume un sentiment universel
en une petite phrase hyper courte et
hyper explicite ça résume en fait tout
haut ce qu'on se dit tous tout bas
pour voir le monde avec des lunettes
roses pour jouer avec nous jouer avec
moi n'hésitez pas le rire et partout nos
rues par exemple sont bourrés de poésie
regardez voilà ça c'est ce que j'adore
faire
les enseignes de coiffure par exemple
donc berbère caractère Buenos Aires
c'est sûr c'est un petit répare les
cheveux c'est
très sympathique et bien sûr ça se
décline à l'infini TIF on a toujours pas
fait le tour de tous les coiffeurs de
France et de Navarre bien sûr il y a
aussi la signalétique regardez par
exemple les gilles voilà mouilles cul
pièce vieille je suis pas sûr
d'avoir très envie de donner mon adresse
dans ce cas là
dans toutes les situations en fait on
peut rire c'est ça que je vais vous dire
dans les situations les plus banales au
supermarché au bureau n'hésitez pas à
regarder comment tordre la réalité
épicer votre vie rire permet de
reprendre le pouvoir
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai décidé de faire
comme j'ai enquêté depuis deux ans sur
le rire je me suis professionnalisé et
je me suis rendu compte incroyable de
tous les bienfaits du rire savez-vous
que le riz est peut-être le meilleur
antistress naturel 15 minutes de rires
par jour et vous avez votre dose d pour
dopamine
voilà accès le ça actif le circuit de la
récompense oh pour aussitôt aussi c'est
l'hormone du bonheur est-ce pour
sérotonine je me dois d'aller demander à
Houellebecq lui c'est et eux pour
endorphine qui a un anxiolytique et un
antidépresseur nature elle mais le rire
a aussi des bienfaits physiques par
exemple il permet de renforcer son
système immunitaire digestif ça permet
de détendre les muscles ça permet de
moduler la douleur ça permet d'avoir une
bonne respiration ça permet de maigrir
sans s'équérir et tout ça pour zéro
franc
et alors là c'est peut-être ce qui m'a
le plus épaté quand j'ai fait mon
enquête sachez que le cerveau ne fait
pas la différence entre un rire forcé et
un rire corrélé à une blague alors il y
a des scientifiques qui ont fait
une étude dans une salle de cinéma et
ils ont donné un stylo à tous les
participants la moitié de la salle
devait prendre son stylo et le mettre
ainsi comme un sourire forcé
l'autre moitié de la salle devait tenir
son stylo comme ça
je vous laisse imaginer qui a préféré le
film sourire permet d'aimer le film de
votre vie il a aussi une autre enquête
que j'ai adoré et que j'ai découvertes
c'est normal cousin c'est un Américain
qui avait une spondylarthrite en
philosophe c'est à dire que c'est
muscles voilà ce courbait et il a décidé
d'abandonner les médicaments
traditionnels pour se soigner à travers
la comédie il avait remarqué que quand
il regardait des films drôles et bien
ses crises s'atténuer et que au bout
d'un moment il était complètement
soulagée alors il s'est installé dans un
hôtel et puis il a regardé plein de
comédie je vous jure qu'il s'est soigné
et qu'il en a créé une méthode
cela dit moi je vais vous raconter
quelque chose d'assez personnel quand je
me suis fait larguer de mon premier
chagrin d'amour comment je me suis
soignée et ben j'ai regardé tout le
splendide et d'une certaine manière les
bronzés et le Père Noël est une ordure
mon sauver
[Rires]
convaincu de tous ses bienfaits du rire
j'espère que vous aussi moi je me suis
lancé donc dans le yoga du rire mais pas
de chien tête en haut ou de chiens tête
en bas vous voyez je suis le rire au
poste de commande en fait le yoga du
rire c'est vraiment la discipline du
lâcher prise comme je vous l'ai dit et
ça permet de s'influencer positivement
face à la vie oui le cerveau était un
muscle
voilà ça s'exerce ça ça apprend
donc n'hésitez pas voilà à à travailler
et à vous y mettre et surtout ce que je
voulais vous dire ce soir mais je pense
que vous l'avez compris c'est que
au-delà de la blague quelque chose de
plus profond se passe et se joue je vais
reciter Romain Gary que j'aime tant et
qui dit que l'humour est une déclaration
de dignité une affirmation de la
supériorité de l'homme sur ce qui lui
arrive
alors si on devait retenir deux choses
ce soir c'est que rire ça fait du bien
et que c'est contagieux donc n'hésitez
pas à propager la Bonne Nouvelle et puis
on va finir comme on va commencer je
vais vous demander de vous relever
ce que j'ai vu que vous étiez très bon
joueur
merci merci c'est génial
et puis on va mettre un pouce en l'air
un deuxième pouce en l'air et puis on va
répéter ensemble je suis formidable
je suis formidable
vive la vie
alors oui oui s'il y a des gens qui
passent là par ici vont vraiment dire
qu'on est une secte de taré mais nous au
moins on s'ennuie pas et ça fait du bien
merci merci
[Applaudissements]